we have new details from Alvin Bragg's
repulsive political Witch Hunt according
to sources that we have Bragg demanded
that Donald Trump turned himself in
today less than 24 hours after the grand
jury voted unfairly to indict him but
because of security concerns the
arraignment won't take place until next
week probably on Tuesday afternoon
Donald Trump will be booked he will be
fingerprinted there'll be a mug shot a
medium mob they will get their so
desired mug shot now my gut instinct
tells me that my friend my colleague
Pete hegseth who was on last name he's
going to be proven correct that
photograph will end up on more t-shirts
and more hats that say Maga and Trump
2024 it will also appear before judge
Juan mershon who by the way the very
same judge who was accused of
railroading the former CFO of the Trump
organization now according to Trump
quote the judge assigned to Mike which
how front case hates me now at this
point would you expect anything less
this is not a criminal case this is a
political Hatchet job and by the way
there will be no settlement according to
a source close to president Trump he
plans to fight this to the very end the
first step will most certainly be a
motion to immediately dismiss all of the
charges on three separate grounds we'll
go over this with our attorneys tonight
in the course of the program one the
faulty legal Theory we don't know the
exact charges but allegedly what Bragg
is doing is attempting to bootstrap a
misdemeanor documents crime to an FEC
charge that has never been done before
and might not even be legal in and of
itself the second thing Trump's lawyers
will likely argue that the case is
beyond the statute of limitations which
they are after all there is a two-year
limit on charges related to mislabeling
documents now the the third reason for a
dismissal involves prosecutorial
misconduct here you have a D.A
responsible for the charges his name is
Alvin but Bragg he ran on a campaign
promise to go after one man Donald Trump
one family the Trump family one
organization the Trump organization now
I think all of that clearly reeks a
political bias uh don't you maybe the
end result should be that he gets
disbarred as the New York Post points
out quote surely the judge will be asked
to consider this question would this
case have been brought against any other
person of course the answer is no in
fact the doj the FEC the Mueller
investigation Bragg's predecessor and
even Bragg himself declined to bring
these charges until now now meanwhile
Alvin Bragg rarely brings felony charges
against anybody in New York even violent
offenders according to an op-ed from
Jonathan Turley he said quote Donald
Trump would have been better off robbing
Stormy Daniels with a gun Bragg would
have thrown that case right out now
Charlie's correct in fact under Bragg 52
percent of every felony case gets
reduced to misdemeanors and of all the
felony cases that Bragg actually brings
to trial he loses 49 percent of the time
in other words he has one of the worst
conviction rates in the entire country
in September a man named Justin
Washington he received a sweetheart deal
from Bragg after allegedly raping a
teenage relative Washington was set to
serve 30 days in jail but before that he
was terrorizing five more victims now
take a look at your screen
here's another sweetheart deal handed
out by Bragg to the perpetrator of a
vicious anti-semitic beating this in
Midtown Manhattan and New York City
Bragg also reduced the charges for a man
who attempted to rob the same Pharmacy
twice in one day at gunpoint I'm sorry
at night point the man this guy had a
lengthy rap sheet more than 20 arrests
for rape robbery assault other crimes
Alvin Bragg didn't care at all in
another case the perpetrator had 46
prior arrests out on parole but Bragg
once again reduced the charges and then
there's the well New York resident known
as Hillary Rodham Clinton she has never
been charged with a crime not in New
York not anywhere to spout despite what
is a mountain of evidence related to a
variety of misdeeds for example the
Clinton campaign and the DNC they
committed the exact same crime that
Donald Trump is now accused of they
mislabeled a campaign expense you know
steals dirty dossier the Russian bought
and paid for dossier well they said that
was a legal expense but there were no
felony charges no criminal
investigations into Clinton instead last
year her campaign merely agreed to pay a
hundred and thirteen thousand dollar
fine never mind that 33 000 deleted
subpoenaed emails those were destroyed
of course uh with something we had never
heard of before bleach bit and then of
course we had devices they were
destroyed with hammers we had SIM cards
removed as well doesn't that sound a
little bit like obstruction of justice
you know to you she was never charged
and her home was never rated and keep in
mind the dossier case that we mentioned
stems from the very same steel dossier
that the Clinton campaign delivered to
James comey's FBI in the lead up to the
2016 election but remember this in early
October 2016 Jim comey's FBI actually
flew across the pond they went to Great
Britain they met with Christopher Steele
and they offered him a million dollars
if he could corroborate that salacious
dossier well even though the steel
dossier couldn't uh be corroborated he
didn't collect his million dollars
because his allegations we now know were
completely BS Comey in late October use
that very dossier contrary to the law
and unlawfully obtained a fiso warrant
to spy on the Trump campaign the Trump
transition team and even the Trump White
House a president of the United States
now at the top of the fisa warrant the
words true and verified are there
dossier was neither but the FBI used it
anyway to get Donald Trump but Comey got
a free pass so did Hillary Clinton with
her classified document Scandal Comey
said no reasonable prosecutor would ever
prosecute but now he's cheering for
Alvin Bragg tweeting Out quote it's been
a good day yesterday Jim Comey is
corrupt he's Petty he's a bureaucrat who
Longs for political vengeance and cares
little about what is called the rule of
law or equal justice under the law or
equal application of our laws now sadly
the current leader of the FBI doesn't
seem to be much better Christopher Ray's
FBI was in possession of Hunter Biden's
laptop from hell since December of 2019
instead of authenticating the laptop and
investigating the Litany of potential
crimes recorded on the laptop while the
FBI they told big Tech in the lead up to
the 2020 presidential race to be on the
lookout for Russian disinformation
related to people like Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden they knew they had the
laptop and big Tech by the way was more
than happy to oblige and they even got
money from the FBI three and a half
million dollars in the case of Twitter
censoring the hunter Biden laptop Story
Only weeks before the election well you
can Count Me In the column as somebody
that believes the FBI knew the laptop
was real they knew it they knew Rudy
Giuliani he had a copy they knew he
would likely release it before the
election and my guess that is the real
reason that the FBI was warning big tech
companies to be on the lookout for
misinformation on people like Joe Biden
and Hunter Biden now to date Hunter has
yet to be charged with any crimes even
though there is video evidence of let's
see Hunter Biden smoking crack cocaine
hiring prostitutes lying on gun
applications selling access to the
federal government uh yet where's that
case there's also extensive evidence
from the laptop and a separate Senate
and House investigation showing that the
big guy and other members of the Biden
family might have benefited from
Hunter's alleged access peddling tax
evasion charges money laundering charges
and now we know there was a real quid
pro quo remember Donald Trump Ukraine
quid pro quo oh Joe Biden's on tape
bragging that that Ukraine won't get one
billion dollars taxpayer dollars unless
they fire a prosecutor in six hours that
prosecutor well ended up getting fired
within six hours Ukraine Got Your
billion dollars meaning taxpayer billion
dollars and guess what son of a bee when
he was fired the investigation that that
prosecutor was doing into going into
with Hunter Biden uh ended right there
and then and Hunter kept getting checks
from Maurice maholdings so let's get
this straight there is video and digital
evidence that Hunter Biden committed
multiple felonies but has never been
charged with a crime his father used
your taxpayer money to protect the
family Syndicate no indictments and on
the other hand Donald Trump is getting
hit with over 30 charges because of a
mislabeled non-disclosure agreement over
an alleged Affair from 2007 that both
parties denied based on testimony from a
convicted felon admitted Liar by the
name of Michael Cohn who we all know is
hell-bent on get getting revenge against
his former boss does that seem like
Equal justice under the law equal
application of our laws to you well of
course it doesn't to me but Democrats
they don't seem to care about Justice
they seem to only care about winning
elections and destroying any and all
political opponents now this far-fetched
case against Trump is not about keeping
New York safe or New Yorkers safe it's
about interfering in the 2024 election
just like the FBI did in 2020 when of
course the hunter laptop from hell that
they had since December of 2019 just
like they did in 2016 with Hillary's
dirty dossier we are now entering a very
very dangerous new era in this country
where Justice is no longer blind where
judges juries DA's have become political
weapons where we have a dual justice
system hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
two page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else